دمروا الحلم كله مسحوه عن بكره ابيه فما
ظل لا حلم لا لطفل لا كبير لا صغير كله
تهدم كله
راح حرمونا من شبابنا من من طفولتهم
الاولاد هدول فالوضع والله جدا
ماساوي ما خلو لي لا حلم ولا مستقبل انا
24 سنه عمري انا كان نفسي اصير
تاجر تاجر عادي مونا والحمد لله تم
هدم محل المحلين تعوني كانوا دكان هذول
كانوا حلمي كانوا هذول اساس البيت رجعنا
لعصر الجاهليه للسفر الاقل من
السفر فالسفر لسه له مكان معين انا في
السالب
قصفوا الدار من هان نسيت كلمه السر تعت
الجوال ونسيت لايلا كمان ومن يومها لليوم
لا الجوال ولا انا
بشتغل قالوا ب بدنا نقص في 11 فرج اللي
انتم فيه نزلنا نجري طلعنا فرشنا حرماتنا
رحنا وقفنا في الساحه قال الابراج وانا
متذكر حتى انا راحت بدي اضي جوالي عشان
اصور واوثق اللحظات الجوال مش ض وتذكرت
موضوع الاي كلاود انا كاتبه على الخزانه
في الدار وهات زل ما يصل الدار هات لي
رغيف خبز وخذ
الاي انا عبد ابو تى من مخيم الشاطئ من
الناس اللي طلعت فوق رؤس الشهداء واحد ي
قلت لما طلعنا احنا كنا عايشين ومبسوطين
لكن هلقيت احنا عايشين اطلع وين وهينا
بنترمولي
وصلونا يعني نحنا كل اللي بدنا اياه بدنا
لا تعمروا لنا ولا تدونا رجعونا ع دور بنا
نحط خيمه وما بدنا شي من هالدنيا لا بدنا
حلم ولا بدنا حاجه كل حلم هلقيت نرجع
لبيتنا كان المفروض زي هذه الايام الحمد
لله بكون خاطب فكل دمر لي كل كل حلمي يعني
ما خلوني لا مجال لا اخطب لا ازبط بيتي
طبعا هذا مش حالي لحالي يعني في حال
المواطنين
كثير نا 77 يوم لا ضحكنا زي
طبي ولا اكلنا اكله زي الخلق قبلونا يا
راكل شاورما
يا يا عم احنا ما بدناش ناكل شاورما ناكل
دقه بس رجعونا على غزه رجعونا على
دورنا فالوضع والله جدا ماساوي يعني احنا
ما مش جاي اشكي انه اقوللك رجعلي اللي راح
بس اطلع على اللي بده يروح
ثاني يلا هاته ه يلا
شاطر